ils n'ont pas toutes et tous la même
étiquette mais font partie de la même
grande famille politique la droite en
vue des municipales en mars 2000 27
acres et pierre que ces élus du
département ont signé la charte du
rassemblement yvelinois c'est la
manifestation denis rey dentiste 1008
moi c'est à dire la volonté des élus
yvelinois de refuser les extrêmes
l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite et
de se mettre d'accord sur un mode de
gestion sur des objectifs communs et on
veut leur apporter à travers le
rassemblement rhinois une espèce de
maisons communes dans lesquelles ils
peuvent se retrouver une maison commune
qui repose sur 7 piliers
parmi eux l'écologie la lutte contre
l'insécurité l'emploi ou encore les
politiques de solidarité c'est la fois
énorme une cohésion une harmonie autour
des élus et les yvelinois est également
un moyen de trouver les bonnes solutions
est à la fois financière et la foi d'
expertise pour les projets à mener futur
et en s'assurant effectivement de
certaines valeurs que nous partageons
parmi les signataires les républicains
mais aussi libre génération terrain udi
objectif avec cette charte proposer une
alternative en réveillant la droite et
le centre
en les amenant à se rassembler nous
souhaitons préparer offrir une
alternative aux françaises et aux
français
je pense qu'il ya pas un maire de gauche
comme de droite en france il souhaite
pas que la france gagne faut qu'on soit
dans cet esprit très largement au dessus
des postures idéologiques dogmatique et
politique qui exècre aujourd'hui les
français
ce document sera soumis aux candidats
des élections municipales qui pourront
s'ils le souhaitent bénéficier du label
rassemblement yvelinois